Where you're from.
Calcutta pitch.
But I'm adopted.
I'm not really,
you're starting to remember.
Beautiful boy.
We're very proud of yourself.
Life.
I'd forgotten
I had another family,
my mother,
my brother.
How can you still see that faces?
I have to find my way back home.
Oh No,
me on the team a couple of days.
Couple of days.
Take a lifetime to search all the stations in India.
Yeah.
Idea what it's like how every day my real brother screams nay
hood that I could take this family together need to survive.
But if you do find
I don't have a choice.
Beautiful.
Every night I imagine that I'm walking those streets and I every single step of
the way.
Whisker and airy.
Hi everyone and thanks for joining us here today.
So to celebrate the release of lion on Google play,
uh wait.
I like tee it up in there.
I have to say,
even even watching the trailer gets me even now to,
to to celebrate the launch of lion on Google play.
We have Saru Brierley here,
uh,
to a fireside chat.
So welcome sir.
[inaudible]
Saru Story and work.
We're going to hear a lot more about serious story I think is particularly
special for us,
uh,
here at Google Australia.
Um,
and so for a couple of reasons,
uh,
you know,
so those surgeries story is a,
is set for a large pot in Tasmania.
A,
so it's a very Australian story.
Uh,
and,
uh,
also as a Google in Australia,
we've been working on Google maps for many years now.
Uh,
and so seeing,
you know,
the kind of things that we've contributed to in the world,
I think it's really special for us.
Um,
I think it's also,
it,
it's an amazing kind of representation of what Google's mission has done in the
world.
So,
you know,
sort of,
uh,
Google's mission is,
to,
you know,
to organize the world's information and make it universally accessible.
And through that,
these amazing stories such as surgery story,
uh,
you've,
you know,
become possible through things like that.
Things like Google Earth.
Uh,
so,
uh,
so we've got Sarah here today.
Uh,
I've got some questions here for Saroo and once some that we've collected from
the dory that was open yesterday and earlier today.
And also later on,
we're going to open it up for questions from the floor.
So please,
uh,
have your questions ready for Saru as well.
So welcome through.
And I think just to start,
we sold the trailer just now,
but maybe you'd like to give everybody,
especially those people who haven't seen the movie a bit more of an explanation
of your story.
Um,
yeah,
that was,
that was really quick,
but it's a 10 hour story that's been compressed into two hours.
And um,
now it's probably even more.
Uh,
but,
um,
I lived in the slums of India,
it's 29 years ago,
and I was only about foggies of agents stool over about a meter in hotch.
And One night I went with my brother from my hometown and caught a train to a
like a neighboring station,
uh,
which was a couple of hours,
um,
just down the road.
And,
um,
and um,
and so,
uh,
we got there about nine at o'clock.
Uh,
so I had a nine o'clock and,
um,
and I was quite Todd and sort of weary and sleepy.
I was the money,
sort of five years of age.
And,
and it's past my bedtime.
um,
and so I grabbed my brother's hand and we stepped off the train and onto the,
the station platform and a saw a chair in front of me.
And so a pooled or by other towards it.
And what my feet are doing,
the talking is,
is they sort of do when you're tired and,
uh,
and I sat down and roboticists stay here for a minute,
I'll come back to get you.
Um,
I went to sleep and,
um,
and when I wake up,
not knowing whether I was asleep for like,
you know,
two hours,
three hours or more,
but,
uh,
when I wake up,
my brother was nowhere to be seen.
And so,
uh,
I thought he's on the train to just standing there with a wrist of same one that
I sort of came from a home town or a different one.
I wasn't,
I wasn't sure of,
but I made that impulse decision,
uh,
groggy impulse decision,
um,
to board the train thinking is on the sort of bordered it went to sleep in a
cubic court,
not knowing that I'm going on a train that has a destination unknown.
So I ended up 32 hours,
um,
1600 kilometers from a safe zone,
to a place called Calcutta where I survive for months.
Going through trials and tribulations of,
uh,
um,
you know,
some of the things of,
uh,
sort of Kemi cross people that said that helped me,
that,
that helped me try and form a hometown,
but the had an ulterior motive.
Um,
and then running away from them and then almost drowning in the Hughley river
twice,
um,
thing to sort of coming across boy gangs,
and then going to work a local prison to a juvenile prison to adoption home.
And then from there being adopted out to Australia,
Tasmania.
Um,
where I was,
looked after,
loved,
um,
showing the Australian way of life,
the culture and so on.
Um,
but always had that in Australia,
the reminiscing of my past and what an oddity it has been for such a long time,
um,
that I couldn't conceive how a child could sort of get,
uh,
from being with his family to getting on a train and getting lost.
Um,
it just didn't make sense even though it was saddening.
I had to,
you know,
find the closure of at least giving it a value and a team in trying to form a
family,
uh,
whichever ways in the means that I've got at hand.
And so in my later sorta 20 later twenties are found Google Earth.
And,
um,
and you know,
I had that option of looking at atlas,
um,
of trying to find burn poor,
which is the only name that are sort of remembered in the way that articulated.
Um,
but I had a really good visual memories.
and I thought,
you know,
if there's such an application,
um,
that I could use on the Internet that are,
could sort of a match what's in my Ma,
in my memories of the landmarks in the architecture of my hometown,
um,
to what I could see on,
you know,
service ways,
Google earth,
then it would make the process so much quicker as opposed to going back to India
and trying to find,
um,
born poor and train station that maybe looks the same,
Eh,
maybe not.
So I went on to Google earth and for years and years or searched from being,
uh,
going haphazardly to becoming quite methodical and strategic in the ways that I
thought about,
um,
looking for my hometown.
And in 2011,
I found that needle in a haystack.
Um,
and in 2012 I'm a fan,
my hometown,
um,
as well as my family as well.
So there was a,
there was a quick version,
even though we're going to have,
you know,
20 coffees and,
uh,
and I'll tell you the 10 hour version,
which I'm happy to do so because,
uh,
at Ed Martin Myself.
But,
um,
but yeah,
it's,
uh,
it,
it pretty much happened like that.
Um,
so,
but,
um,
I listen to myself but dreams,
my gut feelings and uh,
in my memories as well and the in hope and hope and determination,
um,
I was harness with that.
So,
um,
I think that those sorts of points were quite integral to,
to find what I've been longing for such a long time.
It's such an amazing story,
you know,
even even your compressed version like this is just so inspirational.
Um,
it,
the,
the movie has been a huge success worldwide.
What do you think about it?
Uh,
what do you think there is about it that's been,
you know,
so universally acclaimed.
Um,
there's so many attributes to the movie and people see it in so many different
ways.
It resonates in people with so many different weights.
Um,
from,
I guess,
you know,
political,
just scientific too,
um,
uh,
a,
a movement in the community from,
you know,
um,
in regards to adoption from having Ibf,
to having that option,
um,
of adopting as well,
uh,
for couples that want to have children.
Um,
so,
you know,
they're sort of some of the things,
but I mean,
people just see it in different ways,
you know,
from hope and determination and,
um,
I guess,
that's mainly the two things that I get sort of talked about his adoption,
but other people see it in other ways as well,
you know,
is it,
uh,
do you think nurture or nature kind of thing?
Um,
in regards to him when we bring up children?
so it,
um,
I guess,
you know,
there's so many things.
Where did we start?
I wasn't joking when I was saying that watching the trailer,
they was tearing me up.
I,
uh,
I have a young son and I found that the beginning of that film,
who's,
who's seen lion,
I don't know if anybody can him.
Yeah.
Oh,
fabulous.
That's great.
Look everyone at Google and,
uh,
watching,
you know,
watching those scenes where you were last on the train and then surviving in
Cokato.
We're just heartbreaking.
Just like,
you know,
with,
with my own young son in particular and just couldn't think of anything that was
there was like,
wood is more directly tugging on my heartstrings and seeing somebody go through
that.
So I think that is really something very universal,
you know,
and that quest also to,
to try and find your family.
Yeah.
That's,
um,
I guess that particular scene,
you could to be a fighter,
you know,
and to,
to survive you've got to fight,
um,
day by day to live.
And it shocks people when they see a scene like that,
I guess.
And it's like,
you know,
we live in a such a lucky world and the country as well that we're not sort of,
uh,
open to what I went through and seeing that kind of scenery.
So it affects people,
you know,
to,
uh,
depths where they've never really gone to.
And,
um,
and I guess,
you know,
we'll probably the whole film does that really,
but more particularly a specifically that,
you know,
that scene in Calcutta,
which,
you know,
could have been sort of linkedin as well,
but,
um,
but you saw a glimpse of,
you know,
what it's actually like,
thank you for not making it even.
Um,
so,
uh,
one part of the film in particular I wanted to dig into was,
was the search saved myself from,
from when you started,
uh,
you know,
thinking that you really wanted to find your hometown and using technology to do
so.
I'd love to know more about your process.
You know,
we saw some of this in the,
in the film and I don't know how accurately that's representing it.
You know,
we had maps and these search Radii I,
and,
and so forth.
Can you tell us what was your mindset going in and then what did you,
what did you do?
What,
how did that search work look?
Um,
well initially I thought,
you know,
you've got youtube and um,
and you've got access to information as opposed to going to the,
to the library and if you wanted to play the guitar,
why,
why pay a tuition when you can go on to youtube and learn yourself.
And so it all sort of,
you know,
it started from there and I thought,
the Internet has got so much information and one of its Google Earth,
um,
that are,
could use this application,
um,
as opposed to sort of,
you know,
going to India in paying thousands and thousands of dollars and maybe getting
nowhere ever.
And,
um,
and so when Google Earth came about,
I thought,
you know,
not knowing what I'm really getting into because once I started using it,
I became quite obsessed and regimented,
uh,
finishing work,
coming home at five 30,
um,
putting the laptop,
which my girlfriend at the time called and a fat top,
cause I said sat on the couch and there of was,
um,
Dylan was in cook.
Nothing.
So,
um,
until,
you know,
midnight and early hours of the mornings as well,
uh,
to,
you know,
five o'clock and six o'clock in the morning and then get to go to work,
even though it was my family business and rob light,
five to five,
five o'clock was finishing time.
Um,
and um,
and so,
you know,
you became quite obsessed and um,
and not realizing that you shutting the world and a,
a y in concentrating in Toronto find something that she'd been longing for such
a long time.
And,
um,
and so from being haphazard relooking looking to becoming methodical,
it's like,
will you know,
you,
you've got to take things a step at a time.
You've got to use what you know and not what you don't know.
And so I knew that,
you know,
the trains,
um,
when you know,
ran 70,
60 kilometers an hour roughly,
and then I sorta had a rough guesstimate of that.
I was on the train for about 12 hours,
but knowing now it was 32 hours.
So I sort of,
you know,
I didn't really have a lot to go on,
but at least a head something to start,
which is better than nothing.
And,
uh,
and so,
you know,
this,
that's the way the radius line that sort of came about.
It seems like,
you know,
point B but you don't know,
point a and,
and I ended up in Calcutta as we all know it.
And so perhaps these radius like can help in creating a search to conference.
If,
so,
you know,
I'd put a line out from Calcutta and rod down from north to south and that
created that sort of a hemisphere.
And,
uh,
and I knew that,
you know,
the,
the hometown is not going to be straight on the radius line date,
but it's going to be in an hour roughly.
So they gave a bit of a guidance and so you segregated the north of India,
segregated the south of India.
And,
um,
and you know,
you will lift with the sort of a rectangular piece of,
um,
after you know,
years and years of searching and in sort of pushing things apart,
um,
that,
you know,
this is all you're left with.
It's an end.
That radius lawn was almost sort of telling you that,
you know,
this is where he should be looking after segregating those two points north and
south and,
um,
you know,
sort of calling a providence or,
or serendipity,
it's a,
I ended up sort of not that I was ever conceive that I could possibly believe
you could have ended up from the west side of India to the east.
Um,
but let's not have any stones unturned and um,
and take a shot at looking at the west side of media hits.
So I did.
And,
uh,
and I found that needle in a haystack,
which a lot of people thought I couldn't,
um,
in 2011 at around two o'clock in the morning.
So,
um,
you know,
back when I was a teenager,
I thought to myself,
sort in my later teens that,
um,
atlas is no good for me,
but I hope one day that there would be a program not knowing that it's embryonic
at that point of time.
And then in 2005,
2006,
um,
it was there,
the application of Google Earth,
even though I thought about it back then and it became apparent in reality in
2006 when I used it.
And so Google earth is the catalyst of,
um,
you know,
finally my family and I'm sure there are other people out there in the world to
that have,
um,
that have used the program to,
to find what they've been long for such a long time.
Most of us,
I think it's usually our,
our rooftop,
you know,
we take it for granted when we,
when we start out,
you know,
we,
the first thing that everybody does,
it turns out this is universal.
You know,
the first thing everybody does,
we thought that what they do is go visit the Grand Canyon or the Eiffel Tower or
something like that.
But in truth,
everybody types in their home address if it goes it.
Yup.
That is indeed my house.
And in some ways that was actually exactly what you were doing.
Well I did you,
it was a,
exactly the,
the thing that I did.
Um,
I actually saw my mum,
um,
watering the garden.
You guys took a photo in Tazzie.
Yeah.
Did you know that you can feel the gun that he had to have you here but you had
somewhere else to find that was a lot harder for you to find them?
Well,
but it was a,
it's a starting point and uh,
and you know,
it's not,
it wasn't as easy as just getting on Google earth and doing what I did.
You had to sorta arm yourself with information and,
um,
you know,
mom and dad were a major part of my lifestyle,
fortified with the knowledge of,
uh,
of within May,
really of my understanding and so on.
But you know,
there was other parts to myself too,
to having that sort of,
uh,
a nurturing and push,
um,
in wanting to also,
you know,
keep going as well because a lot of people can,
can become,
um,
you know,
this is,
this is just a waste of time.
It's so futile.
And let's give up.
You said it was five years from,
from when you started using earth to try and find it until 2011 when you did.
Yes.
How do you keep,
how do you keep going?
That's,
you know,
our,
until a lot of people about it because,
um,
uh,
as well as there's two things to it.
The other thing was,
uh,
the first was a astral projections and a lot of people would find it really hard
and years and years to ever come to that point of astral projection and astral
projection is where you have that out of body experience.
And I had asked for projections,
um,
when I came to Australia,
always had that sort of the outer body experience,
um,
of,
you know,
going to sleep.
Hence why I wake up in the morning a bear with a sore head because I never
really slept.
Um,
I had this thing in the subconscious going on and coming into astral projection
of going out body space and then materializing at the door of my house where I
was born in going in and hovering over from our family to tell them that are
there are my chi in Monte.
I'll see you.
Um,
so,
you know,
there was that in the reoccurring dreams and,
and someone,
I didn't really know what it meant.
I really didn't tell people until my parents until sort of later on,
but the other sort of,
uh,
integral part two,
which are in really tell many people about as well.
Um,
because I just don't,
I have that understand it much,
but having people that are,
um,
ancient philosophers and mathematicians and,
and uh,
like,
you know,
Isaac Newton and Nikola Tesla and,
uh,
Pythagoras and all those people,
um,
these people have left a legacy on the cert.
And I've always looked towards him as in like,
you guys have lean,
um,
transcended in finding things as well as,
Martin Luther King,
you know,
that these are great people.
And I thought,
you know,
hope I could be like you guys one day too of trying to fulfill something that
I've been wanting for such a long time and um,
and you know,
read about them in so on and in there a real inspiration to me because when you
have Kenya West and Nikola Tesla,
everyone know who's Kenya Wiz,
but no one would really know who this other person is.
Tesla,
it was actually a pretty good rapper.
Oh,
was it?
Yeah.
Um,
um,
but yeah,
it was a great philosopher to,
um,
but yeah,
these people were sort of a quite integral part of my life to,
um,
they helped in making me want to keep going because they didn't stop.
They kept on going and not having much help from other people too.
It's a very autonomously tribe.
And so for you was the autonomous as well?
Like A,
I'm hearing about this amazing internal drive that you had w you know,
did anybody else help you through this,
that,
what you did you get friends to,
you know,
look on earth as well?
Was it was,
it was,
it was all by myself.
You know,
I didn't want to tell many people about it because I thought by telling people,
even to my parents,
they would slow me down and I would go through the phase and stage and the steps
that I need to go,
even though sometimes,
or maybe sort of veering away.
Uh,
but it's all a learning curve.
You know,
if I make a mistake,
we'll,
I've learned something that I can sort of realign myself in going the directions
that are need to.
So I thought that by telling people that would slow me down by Saru,
look,
that's the past.
This is now,
and it's the future.
Forget about the past.
Um,
you know,
it,
you're in a lucky place with a great family.
Um,
and um,
and you know,
I think your past is sort of really putting it down into progressing in your
life.
And,
um,
and,
you know,
if I had listened to them,
even though we're just trying to look after me as friends,
would,
um,
maybe,
you know,
I wouldn't be here in this story,
would be never,
never come about.
But you know,
I didn't,
I didn't want to listen.
You know,
I wanted to do something that I wanted to do the think outside the square that
you're living and um,
and,
and listen to your mind and you've got feelings of that.
Um,
so,
so yeah,
it's,
uh,
it's one of those things that,
you know,
you've got to sort of do yourself and I'm not other people have you influence.
Um,
but,
um,
it was,
it was a personal journey,
a story like this of a,
of my paths.
He just don't tell to anyone.
You know,
it's,
it's private.
Um,
and I'm sure we all have private stories that were not want to tell your best
friend or your mom,
but I'm in the,
this was my private story that,
you know,
I wanted to do things myself and I didn't want to shoot too far ahead of myself.
It's like,
you know,
hey,
I'm using Google earth and this is,
people would come up and say,
oh,
why don't you do these,
why you do that?
And it becomes very cluttered and you've got to,
you know,
sort of defragment you tried to defragment yourself,
let alone have other people's problems coming in and influences,
you know,
I achieved better by myself.
Um,
acquiring knowledge from other people but not have other people sort of invest
themselves healthy.
So you were just five when you,
when you left your home or when you,
you,
you're on the train.
What were the memories that you took with you that you used later on?
You know,
what were the things that,
that you were able to keep with you that when you were doing your search helped
you,
helped you find your home?
The,
the bond between mother and son and,
and my siblings,
especially my sister,
you know,
that there was a,
there was a,
there was fused pretty well,
you know,
I wasn't a child that was taken and then,
sort of let go of I was,
I was the last chart.
Not,
not that was any fault of my own.
Um,
I suppose it would have been a different situation if I was just had been sort
of handed over and said,
you know,
punch it anymore,
it would have been a totally different story.
Um,
but the yearning of wanting to,
you know,
find my mother and especially,
my sister as well because I was her carer.
Um,
the,
you know,
there was a major drive as in when it comes to family,
will number would ever let go of family.
And I didn't want to be disrespectful to my adoptive family,
but in my letter age,
you know,
I'm sort of coming up to 30 and I'm an adult.
Um,
it's,
I mean,
I didn't tell them about my searching,
um,
but until I sort of,
you know,
sort of later on had,
um,
achieve what I wanted to achieve.
And then what a toll ideal.
Actually,
I told them it's like a farmer high intense.
Is it okay with your permission that I go back and,
you know,
and they gave me their permission.
It's,
yes,
we would do that,
would want the same thing.
Um,
if were in your position.
So,
um,
so it was all to do with family really,
you know,
and,
um,
and not to give up,
as well as to diffuse those weights on my shoulders that had been there for such
a long time,
which was driven from wanting to,
you know,
find out that my mother's okay.
And she's still alive.
And my sister as well,
you know,
she was so tiny,
so little to watch your fingers and if in a fake,
because there,
so Marie and she was waiting charcoal and uh,
because there was no food,
I couldn't provide anything.
I'm just thinking about it,
which is,
you know,
put tears to your eyes.
So when you did find your hometown on Google Earth,
how recognizable was it?
Because you know,
the,
the imagery presumably was a lot different from when you had left and you know,
and that your memories of it from what you had left,
you know,
how did,
how did you really know that you'd found the right place?
Um,
I'm a great person with convincing myself with three things.
so when I saw it for the first time in the subconscious,
I know it's the place,
but also wanted to see it from,
um,
a video which was youtube.
And so I just taught the name and then all of a sudden there was people going
through Canva,
my home town camcorder,
high definition too.
And,
um,
and I was like,
where that's like,
he can't be any more convinced.
And additionally to that,
I went onto Facebook and typed in Conway and there was,
um,
Canva is my hometown,
home homepage or Facebook page.
And I wrote to the administrator asking you all these questions and he's coming
back with positive answers.
So there was,
there was Google earth,
there was Facebook,
there was youtube and you know,
that consolidated,
um,
it really,
everything is in like,
even though I was feeling quite,
this is not right steal,
but hey,
I really love hearing that,
that it's,
you know,
in the,
in the movie it's all very much about,
you know,
you're matching up the imagery and so on.
But the other sources that you're talking about,
things like youtube and Facebook,
just point to the way that the Internet has really transformed information these
days.
Right?
Like we have this expectation that we can go on and find anything,
as you said about,
uh,
you know,
whether it's a,
a youtube video to help you learn guitar or somebody walking down the streets of
your hometown on the other side of the world.
It's all out there.
Yeah.
Well,
I certainly embraced it,
you know,
um,
I,
I think,
you know,
I mean,
there wasn't any other way really.
And uh,
and imagine what the earth could be like if everyone else sort of felt like that
too,
of,
um,
uh,
just using sort of the,
the,
the Internet and whatever they wanted to find.
Um,
yeah.
So,
and to understand something which is different from your own situation too,
to see something,
you know,
that's not just your hometown,
you're not your,
where you live yourself,
but something else where in the world.
Yeah.
Um,
can you,
um,
can you describe how it felt when you,
when you got there and you know,
when,
when you really knew that you were there standing in your home?
I can't fathom what that would,
it would feel like I'd,
I'd love to hear from you.
You know,
it's such a pivotal moment.
And um,
and um,
it was,
uh,
I got to my hometown,
through my bag in the corner of the hotel and it came to a,
a,
a spot where I sort of,
uh,
always went to before either going to sort of the city or going back to home.
So it was,
it sort of a central spot for everyone really,
um,
going to the city and suburbia.
And this was in your memory from,
from when you were five?
You can,
you can,
I mean,
pointing,
it's the landmark that I would go to all the time.
And so as soon as I got to this landmark,
which is sort of the,
uh,
bridge with an underpass,
um,
my legs head sort of muscle memory and they just guided me,
you know,
I'm looking around thinking,
this place looks really different,
but you know,
these legs knew everything amazing.
And,
um,
and they were just taking me to,
to the,
the,
the door of my,
you know,
my house where I was born and,
um,
and I'm trying to fight,
you know,
in a sort of a,
a state of,
in differences in why does everything looks so small and decayed as well.
Um,
and it's been 25 years and things just don't last forever.
And you know,
houses have sort of fallen apart,
crumbled and a new houses on top of the old houses have been built upon.
Um,
and things look small.
It's because,
you know,
when you were so short with small,
um,
everything looks so big,
but now he's so tall,
everything would just look so small and,
um,
it's a,
you know,
you,
you were sort of finding that and it's like I'm extrapolating,
um,
in,
in trying to make sense of things.
But when I got to,
you know,
uh,
the front door and it looked a bit sort of,
um,
there's no one there and worst,
the worst sort of got into you and thought you know,
their data and move somewhere else or they're not alive anymore.
Um,
and then,
you know,
a few people came along and asked,
um,
questions about,
you know,
who are you and where you're from and what you're doing and what you're looking
for.
Um,
and then,
you know,
that process of telling them who I am in,
um,
where I'm from and who my family members,
uh,
began.
And so,
so that,
that,
that point where I was standing in front of the door of my house,
it's the same point where I was,
uh,
before leaving to catch that train 25 years ago.
Um,
to burn poor before I went onto their fry for night to Calcutta.
So,
uh,
there's a lot of,
um,
uh,
recurrences and,
um,
you know,
but this happened then in 25 years.
This happened again at the same spot.
So,
uh,
themes always come in that I'm signed to realize from an outsider looking in,
but amazing.
Um,
I'd like to switch now and ask you some questions from Googlers here and also
across a atrium and a in the Pacific.
Uh,
so here's one.
How has the technology changed from when you were on your search and do you
think it would be any easier for you today?
Yes.
You know,
be a d the high definition I guess.
Um,
or plus the in regards to Google earth or movies out,
you can just watch the movie and he had no,
yeah,
that's,
that's the other piece I didn't think about,
but um,
but it Gusta Google Earth,
right?
Yeah.
Good analogy overall.
Um,
I mean it is,
it's just so much out there really.
And then where do you start?
Um,
but I think,
you know,
it's up to the person really the wants to know,
um,
it's up to them to press that button and wanted to search for things and so on.
Um,
it's at the touch of your fingers,
everything that we want,
but it's really up to you really if you want it to,
um,
venture into that journey of,
I don't know,
expanding your mind.
Yeah.
Um,
people in this office are working on apps for what's described as the next
billion users.
So this is people in developing nations such as India who starting to access the
internet mostly on mobile phones.
What services or features do you think would be useful if you were a young
person living in India today?
Ooh,
I love these brands.
Brian bursting question.
Um,
as a young person,
I mean there's this,
uh,
you know,
such a different degree of,
from poverty to people,
um,
in the sectors of society and their availability to access,
even if even a phone,
I guess starters before even going into applications.
Um,
so,
but I mean,
the cost is everything isn't it these days.
Um,
and the,
the,
the availability of
having that sort of,
um,
something that is cost effective and attainable for a kid,
I guess?
Um,
it is a big question.
So,
um,
if I was in the situation as my nieces and nephews are,
I guess I'm not too sure,
just it'd be a cost factor.
Yeah.
Because not everyone can afford it.
Have you spent much time back there since you've found your original family?
15 times.
I've been back within the four years,
um,
which has been great because,
you know,
the,
the big tent event in Delhi,
you know,
went back,
um,
to do a talk there,
which allowed me to go and see my family and then also with the book and going
back and we tracing everything with Marcos rider,
um,
which allowed me again to see my family and then,
the movie as well.
Um,
as well as,
you know,
literally fests and other events.
So it's been,
it's been really good to,
um,
to have all these things.
And uh,
on the side I've always gone to see my family.
But,
um,
additionally to that too,
I've,
I've seen the orphanage as well,
quite a lot.
Um,
there has to be harmony and um,
and I've been quite sort of grateful for um,
what's happened to me but there are children out there,
um,
you know their stories a little bit different and it's what's happened to them
too.
So helping at the orphanage is a major,
major thing that I want to do and have been me um,
as well as well as seeing my family too.
I'm going to open up to the floor here in Sydney as well.
I'm sorry for the people in other offices that I can't move it up to you.
Um,
there's a couple of microphones and I see a first question up here and then a
second one over on this side.
Hello.
Thanks for coming.
First of all,
amazing story.
I just wanted to ask,
have you had a chance to try Google earth in there recently?
Recently released a virtual reality?
Reminds me of what you were saying about astral projection.
It's quite a powerful experience even for someone who doesn't have the,
the story that,
that you have.
If you haven't tried it,
we'd be happy to show you.
Is that the,
uh,
the liquid?
This is the via other VR.
Oh,
no,
I haven't.
I haven't,
but,
um,
but yeah,
sure.
I'd love to love to try it as long as not scary is that,
you know what I did,
we're sending you home with a daydream view today.
Sorry.
We should be getting hung up on Google Earth on Vr soon.
That'd be fun.
Love to,
yeah,
I haven't tried to get butter.
Okay.
And there was a question just over here as well.
Thanks so much for coming here.
Awesome.
Listen to you.
Um,
I,
he went about a lot of people who come into a bet with like bad circumstances or
big sort of setbacks and they almost become fearless afterwards because they
know that they probably won't hit that low again.
And you talk about your ambition to kind of leave a legacy in the same night as
Tesla and these guys,
I'm wondering if your experience has made you somewhat fearless against the kind
of threats that would,
or that the setbacks that you could face in that pursuit.
Yeah,
yeah.
I guess,
you know,
being in,
being in Calcutta,
um,
you had to be fearless and,
now being an adult,
you know,
um,
I guess that's sort of being in a lucky country.
Um,
and you become,
I don't know,
it was sort of
more fear I guess,
because you're not in the,
um,
you're not in the same world,
in the same realm.
Um,
you know,
there's,
there's India which you,
you know,
you far to serve.
Our thing is Australia.
Um,
it,
you know,
it's a westernized world as opposed to,
in a different world.
Um,
and,
and I guess I've become a bit soft.
Um,
but it,
that Saru as a child,
you know,
as a five year old,
a contending what he did reminds me of like,
you know,
if Saru saw you now kind of thing,
I'm getting scared in front of a spotter,
he'd be like,
he'd be shame on you.
You know what I mean?
So he always reminds me,
he's that little guidance to give me strength or the time.
Um,
you sometimes we get,
um,
but yeah,
I mean,
um,
I'm very lucky to have them.
So even though it's me,
he reminds me of self is like,
look what you've,
uh,
look what you've done and what look what you've conquered and what you've been
through and so on.
And,
um,
so,
so I always get reminded by him.
Yeah.
I thought,
I see question.
He's really,
thank you so much for coming in.
I really enjoyed listening to you.
I've got,
I'd love to hear more about what your family are doing now,
your mom and your sister and what they're up to.
Yeah,
look,
Hey,
one of the things is I bought my mom house and um,
um,
you know,
before when I was,
uh,
as children,
we couldn't afford anything really.
We lived on renting and,
uh,
and having milk,
um,
pre match the most,
you know,
something's sustainable as opposed to other things as well,
which we couldn't afford.
But I built her a house.
I bought her a house,
which is the same house,
um,
you know,
that she's been living in for the last 25 years.
And,
um,
and she didn't want her to move to another house.
She wanted to stay there.
Her friends are close by.
Um,
I helped my sister out,
I helped my brother out.
Um,
and they've,
you know,
they've got houses will,
um,
and helping,
you know,
my niece and nephews as well,
um,
for sort of school league and someone.
Um,
so,
you know,
there,
there are,
there were,
they're doing okay.
So,
um,
I'm happy to do that in term and why wouldn't anyone else do the same thing
anyway?
So my question was actually very similar,
um,
about your family.
Obviously this is a very incredible story and a story that the world has
attached itself to and wants to hear in his care that some international
attention,
um,
and your family is very excited now that you found them and you're reconnected.
How do they feel about the,
the international exposure of this story?
Is it something that is,
you know,
difficult for them or do they really want to share it?
And I imagine that that's a very personal thing.
My biological family.
Yeah.
Look.
Um,
I don't,
I don't think they really understood the extent of what this story is globally
in the book and the movie.
Um,
um,
I think that there's just very conservative people,
and,
um,
and I don't think it's sort of hit them,
until sort of now of what it really is and,
and how sort of,
uh,
amazing ease to people.
Uh,
it's a unique,
profound story.
And,
um,
and I guess they're a bit like me to,
you know,
seeing is believing.
You know,
I heard a lot of things,
but,
you know,
sorry.
It's,
uh,
it made my feelings change and so now it's really hit them in days.
They're just,
um,
they're quite sort of a,
you know,
like,
wow,
really,
this is my son.
This is us,
the story about,
um,
what has happened.
So,
um,
but you know,
that they're,
they're humbling,
great,
full about everything.
And I think the end of the day for them is really,
um,
that,
you know,
I'm back in their lives.
I,
how are you sleeping patterns now?
Like,
Oh,
where do I start?
I mean,
I just got in from Bahrain last night,
not building sandcastles,
but,
um,
once you found your home town,
yeah,
it did.
Um,
the,
you know,
the weights on much shoulders diffused and those dreams of the astral projection
or that stopped,
I don't have them anymore.
I haven't had them for four years.
So I mean that,
that gives me a better sleep.
I guess.
I'm not,
so you sort of moody in the morning,
not wanting to,
um,
do my sort of chores in the house,
back then.
But you know what,
actually just expand on that.
Having those astral projection isn't always a good thing for people,
you know,
having to,
uh,
having flashes come back at you during the night and during the day,
um,
it's not having a photographic memory of things isn't always great of being
retold something that you don't want to see anymore or think about anymore.
So,
but I'm very fortunate,
lucky that,
you know,
those astral projections and dreams were there for a reason,
a guidance from our brother there was pushing and pulling the,
the energy of the universe,
you know,
being there to the planets or celebrity or beans aligning in a way,
um,
to,
to find my way back home.
I haven't got to quick hypothetical questions.
The first is,
uh,
how long would you have kept on looking at you not found him after five years.
And the second is if you could guide yourself,
your five year old self to get on the right train,
would you have done or
would you just keep going on the wrong train?
Um,
I would have searched,
you know,
until the dialer died.
So it's not something I would've given up when I,
when I came across something.
Um,
I don't give up,
you know,
I believe that everything is possible in this world.
Um,
it's,
life is just a jigsaw.
What we want to do in finding things,
whatever it may be.
As crazy as it sounds,
there's,
there's a way of getting there.
It's just takes time to get there.
Um,
so for me,
you know,
oh,
I would have,
would have kept on going.
Um,
but in regards to the train,
you know,
sometimes sometimes catching the wrong train can get you to the right station.
And that's how,
I guess it was for me,
even though I went through,
uh,
so much trials and tribulations that came out at the end,
from my mother's adoptive mother's perspective,
traumatized but are disassociated myself,
you know,
even though I always had the memories and it,
but I didn't let them overtake me.
So,
um,
uh,
you know,
I guess it was just my destiny to go through what I did and,
uh,
and it,
it just happened that way.
You know,
some of it not so sort of a fruitful and nice,
but you know,
it just happened that way and let's not sort of cry over spilled milk.
So,
um,
one of the soon as it touched me in the film was when you set off the train and
spoke a different language to the people who surrounded you.
Um,
I'm just curious as to,
uh,
do you recall any of it?
I think it was Hindi in the films where it's presented.
Do you still speak in Hindi?
Do you remember any of you learned 10,
he's since been reconnected with your family?
Yeah,
look,
um,
I only knew about six to seven words of Hindi.
That's it.
I can't even,
I couldn't even string a sentence together and hence,
you know,
I couldn't articulate,
uh,
being coming to Calcutta was,
it,
you speak Bengali there.
So I didn't speak Bengali and,
um,
only spoke sort of,
you know,
a few words of helion.
That's it.
My best friend was my sister.
She couldn't even talk anything saying,
and,
um,
and so it was,
you know,
that that was against me.
And,
um,
and you know,
the first thing that you learned as a child is what's your mom's names?
Uh,
your last name,
your father's name,
financial and the street that you live in.
But I didn't have that,
you know,
my knowledge was very minimal.
Um,
and I had to use more visual memories,
which will Hartness as opposed to my auditorium.
And,
um,
and that's why I have these memories of my past in the hometown and the
architecture of the place and so on.
So,
um,
so yeah,
a cow.
Carter was,
uh,
was very difficult.
You know,
it was a no one would understand what I was saying really.
Um,
but when I asked her,
you know,
foreign poor,
no one would know.
It's like,
where,
what's next?
It's been fine.
I determination commitment to a cause.
What's Nice,
uh,
well it's a bit crazy,
but I want to get into physics.
So,
um,
space propulsion.
Yeah.
I'm not going to shoot myself what I'm going to do with it,
but you know,
that's,
um,
that's a,
that's a bit ahead of my time,
but that's next for me.
But,
um,
I'm learning the process of writing the Prequel to line,
uh,
which is talking about,
um,
how,
from adoptive mother to my biological mother to Serratia sued the lady that,
um,
that helped,
you know,
at the orphanage,
uh,
to get to me,
to Australia.
Um,
how they're all sort of related and,
uh,
from,
you know,
states apart to oceans apart and how,
um,
their dreams and what they want to do in life in regards to helping children has
come about.
Um,
you know,
from Serratia sued.
He's the,
the owner of the orphanage in India,
Isa.
Um,
how no,
she three went through her trials and tribulations,
um,
with another trailer tracer helping her out and so on.
And then wanting to go out by herself and her family situation as well from
being a lawyer,
um,
to wanting to help children in India that are in so much need.
So I think,
um,
putting,
you know,
the prequel out the story,
uh,
a book first and then hopefully,
maybe next,
um,
would really make people understand even more in depth what lines about as well.
Because it,
it goes even deeper.
So there's that aim mol crazy thing as well.
I think that's a really great place for us to wrap up.
So Sarah,
thank you so much for your time and coming in.
Thank you.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].